I tell you what man with this online
trip man dark you make the internet
easier man that's why I moved in next to
our coach okay so the problem is that
you were using a computer like a
whiteboard okay and say what how do i
craft another QP Oh welcome to this
year's dress I'm back I can finally meet
my employees now we've created digital
recreation so that players can still hug
me I love you daddy
what the hell I thought we programmed
out the booze alright first pick is the
bangles you're on the clocks that Taylor
Oh return of Ezekiel with my first pick
on obviously taking we've been hacked do
you want to play oh hell yeah I love my
games no one can make us make terrible
picks yeah I could totally see them
doing that okay the Dolphins trap but my
after windpipe baby yells hey I know
Cody Park publicly and emotionally
throwing things from six feet away
you're going down Falls [ __ ] had a
weird career think who's the one person
that cut beef with everybody nope not me
I'll take care now probably genius I
better call them hey Cochise I just want
you to know I've been grinding working
real hard
okay James just said you don't need to
meet this phone I don't think it's him
Patriots Street it up was anybody
computers oh well we'll take to it but
you don't think Belichick was the hacker
there's no way you take advantage of
unique situation better than any of us
I'm watching your resume calls to okay
let's cut to our joint coverage of the
drab I just think that you know you go
you know you
[Music]
Wow
[Music]